chris farley my favorite comedian of all
time no one makes me laugh I will argue
to anybody
people go oh Belushi this I I don't
think you put Farley in the same room as
any of these guys there's nobody that
makes me laugh as hard as possible with
almost everything he does and the best
[ __ ] thing and nobody probably knows
this except if your industry is you
created motivational speaker Matt for
actually a lot of people know well thank
you well no I think a lot of people in
the industry know it heard about a lot
and I and I okay look the truth is I am
really proud of it because I did write
it pretty much exactly the way he
performed it and I'd wrote it alone in
my apartment in Chicago and Chris had
done a version of the character in an
improv like the night before but none of
the story of the script or none of
nothing none of that [ __ ] was in there
you know how he'd seen a version of the
character and that and it's such a
performance heavy thing so I'll share
credit on inventing the thing because he
did that a version of that character and
that inspired my brain so you know rain
wrote you created that well the story of
it the scenario is all me lives in a van
but this guy I mean he would it was the
greatest thing I ever was a part of I
think just pure simple one thing my
daughter once asked me what's the best
thing you ever did and I said doing that
writing that scene and doing it eight
times a week it's at Second City because
like you I feel like there was nothing
greater than seeing Chris be funny and
act and and I was on stage with him
because I played the dad a teen and so
to have him do that right in front of
you every night and by the way different
every night a little different every
night every single night he would not
quit until he made you laugh until he
made everyone on stage laugh and the
audience came along and
boy I'll never forget it was the
greatest thing and what it was happening
you're like this is the greatest thing
I've ever I'll ever do yeah even you
know I'm glad you said that because I
think it's like if I'm in a bad mood I
know that I put that best of SNL Chris
Farley on and I watched the motivational
speaker I watch and I memorize that
whole thing I you know I was like I am a
skinny Farley I would and I got a chance
to hang out I was good friends with
Kevin and Johnny I guess I got to really
you know and I was just went when he
passed I was just as many but I write
about him a lot in my memoir which is
coming out in about a year and a half
and please come back right before comes
out sure yes yeah I I did I write about
him a lot what is it what is that you
write what is it that you is it
emotional when you write it well some of
it is I don't know some of its kind of
sad and I don't know how you felt about
it but you say you know or you got to be
with them a bit well I mean I got to
hang out with him a couple times with
you know those guys and spend some time
but it was always funny and laughing and
drinking it wasn't you know I know that
the demons and I know from his brothers
and I know you know I think the hardest
part for me was just we just my father
was an alcoholic and I learned a lot
about alcoholism when I was young
because my mom took me to al-anon which
is a great thing to attend if you have
an alcoholic in your family family
members of people with alcoholism can
meet and talk about the things are going
through and the hardest part was how
just how inevitable it all felt
everything that in Chris's story the way
it played out